This episode is brought to you by Accenture. When your advertising operations fall out of sync, everything else follows. Spotify and Accenture are working together to reinvent the rhythm of ad sales, using automation, analytics, and smarter workflows to simplify campaign delivery and access better data across the business. The result? Less time spent on operations, more time connecting brands with the moments and fandoms that matter most. Learn more at Accenture.com slash Spotify.
本期节目由埃森哲赞助播出。当你的广告运营脱节时，其他一切也会随之脱节。Spotify和埃森哲正在合作重塑广告销售的节奏，利用自动化、分析和更智能的工作流程来简化广告系列交付，并获取整个业务中更好的数据。结果如何？花在运营上的时间更少了，将品牌与最重要的时刻和粉丝群体联系起来的时间更多了。请访问 Accenture.com slash Spotify 了解更多信息。
Speaking of psychology is taking a summer break, so we're rerunning some of our favorite episodes from the past. In 2023, I talked to psychologist Tim Cavell and Lauren Quech about why parenting expectations seem higher than ever and how parents can focus on what really matters most. I hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. We'll be back with new episodes beginning August 26th. Raising children can be particularly challenging these days. There are dozens of books and articles offering competing answers to nearly every parenting question you might have, from how to get your baby to sleep, to how to help siblings get along, to how much screen time is too much, to whether let your tween attend a sleepover.
本期《心理学热线》进入暑假模式，因此我们将重播过去一些最受欢迎的节目。在2023年，我与心理学家蒂姆·卡韦尔（Tim Cavell）和劳伦·奎奇（Lauren Quetch）探讨了为什么育儿期望似乎比以往任何时候都高，以及父母如何专注于真正最重要的事情。希望大家喜欢这期来自档案库的节目。我们将在8月26日开始回归全新节目。如今，养育孩子可能特别具有挑战性。有数十本书籍和文章对几乎每一个你可能遇到的育儿问题给出相互竞争的答案，从如何让宝宝入睡，到如何帮助兄弟姐妹融洽相处，再到多少屏幕时间才算太多，以及是否让你的青少年参加留宿派对。
Meanwhile, every parenting decision you make, even the most mundane ones, can feel consequential. It's no wonder that many parents feel tired, stressed, and unsure of whether they're doing a good job. In a recent Pew Research Center survey, 47% of mothers and 34% of fathers said they felt that parenting was tiring most or all of the time, and one-third of mothers and one-quarter of fathers felt it was stressful all or most of the time. So as a parent, how do you know which of your choices matter most and where to focus your limited parenting energy? What's the right balance between keeping kids safe and giving them freedom?
与此同时，你所做的每一个育儿决定，甚至是那些最平凡的决定，都可能感觉意义重大。难怪许多父母感到疲惫、压力重重，并且不确定自己是否做得很好。在皮尤研究中心最近的一项调查中，47%的母亲和34%的父亲表示，他们觉得育儿在大部分或所有时间都令人疲惫，三分之一的母亲和四分之一的父亲觉得育儿在所有或大部分时间都令人压力山大。因此，作为父母，你如何知道自己的哪些选择最重要，以及该将有限的育儿精力集中在哪里？在确保孩子安全与给予他们自由之间，什么是正确的平衡？
How should you respond when your kids try your patience with whining, sibling fights, or teenage sarcasm? How should your parenting change as your kids get older? And most important, how can you develop a loving, supportive relationship with your children that will stand the test of time and lead to a happy, well-adjusted family? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
当你的孩子用哭闹、兄弟姐妹争吵或青少年的讽刺来考验你的耐心时，你应该如何反应？随着孩子的长大，你的育儿方式应该如何改变？最重要的是，你如何才能与孩子建立一种充满爱意、支持性的关系，经受住时间的考验，并建立一个幸福、适应良好的家庭？欢迎收看《心理学热线》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
We have two guests today. They are the authors of a new book published by the American Psychological Association called Good Enough Parenting, a Six-Point Plan for a Stronger Relationship with Your Child. First is Dr. Tim Cavell, a professor in the Department of Psychological Science at the University of Arkansas, and a practicing psychologist. Dr. Cavell's research focuses on parent- and mentor-based interventions for children at risk, including programs for aggressive children and chronically bullied children. Dr. Cavell is also published more than 60 research articles and chapters, as well as several books for clinicians who work with at-risk kids and their families. He's also the father of three children who are now in the 20s and 30s. Our second guest today is Dr. Lauren Quetch, also a professor in the Department of Psychological Science at the University of Arkansas and a licensed clinical psychologist.
我们今天有两位嘉宾。他们是美国心理学会出版的新书《足够好的育儿：与孩子建立更牢固关系的六点计划》（Good Enough Parenting, a Six-Point Plan for a Stronger Relationship with Your Child）的作者。首先是蒂姆·卡韦尔博士，他是阿肯色大学心理科学系教授，也是一名执业心理学家。卡韦尔博士的研究重点是针对高危儿童的基于父母和导师的干预措施，包括针对攻击性儿童和长期遭受霸凌儿童的项目。卡韦尔博士还发表了60多篇研究文章和章节，以及几本面向与高风险儿童及其家庭合作的临床医生的书籍。他也是三名现年二十多岁和三十多岁孩子的父亲。我们今天的第二位嘉宾是劳伦·奎奇博士，她同样是阿肯色大学心理科学系的教授，也是一名持牌临床心理学家。
Her work focuses on children with disruptive behavior and autism spectrum disorder, and in particular helping parents of children with autism build stronger, parent-child relationships. She also works with community mental health agencies in an effort to help families get access to evidence-based treatments faster. Dr. Quetch is the mother of four young children. Dr. Cavell's and Dr. Quetch's book aims to help the parents of children from toddlers to teens learn practical, science-based strategies to build healthy and lasting parent-child relationships. Thank you both for joining me today. Thank you for having me. Good to be here. Let's start with the title of the book and why you chose it. What does it mean to be a good enough parent, and why should
她的工作重点是患有破坏性行为和自闭症谱系障碍的儿童，特别是帮助自闭症儿童的父母建立更强大、健康的亲子关系。她还与社区心理健康机构合作，努力帮助家庭更快地获得循证治疗。奎奇博士是四个幼儿的母亲。卡韦尔博士和奎奇博士的书旨在帮助从幼儿到青少年的父母学习实用的、基于科学的策略，以建立健康和持久的亲子关系。非常感谢两位今天做客节目。谢谢邀请我。很高兴来到这里。让我们从书名以及你们为什么选择这个名字开始。成为一个足够好的父母意味着什么，为什么
parents aim for good enough as opposed to spectacular or out of this world? We must concede that the term was borrowed. The phrase, good enough mother was coined back in the 50s by a psychologist named Donald Winnicott. And the phrase, good enough parenting has been around for quite a while. In fact, you could probably find two or three books with similar titles that might invoke the term good enough or good enough parenting. It's interesting if you look at the history of one of a cot's use of the term because he thought that the perfect parent was less effective than the good enough parent. And what he meant by that was that the good enough parent doesn't always meet every child's
父母应该以足够好为目标，而不是追求壮观或非凡？我们必须承认，这个词是借用来的。“足够好母亲”这个短语是由心理学家唐纳德·温尼科特（Donald Winnicott）在50年代提出的。“足够好育儿”这个短语也已经存在相当长一段时间了。事实上，你大概能找到两三本书名相似的书，它们可能会借用“足够好”或“足够好育儿”这个词。如果你回顾温尼科特使用这个词的历史，会发现很有趣的一点，因为他认为完美的父母比足够好的父母效率更低。他的意思是，足够好的父母并不总是能满足孩子的每一个
need. In fact, he used the term fail. Sometimes they fail to meet their child's every need. And in so doing, children learn to cope on their own. And we think that's an important message for today's parent because there's tons of information. To me, it feels like a wait to try to be a good parent. It seems that if the bar has been set to perfect or at least quote unquote effective, and we wanted to write a book that describes in a more holistic fashion,
需求。事实上，他用了“失败”这个词。有时他们在满足孩子的每一个需求方面会失败。通过这样做，孩子们学会了自己应对。我们认为这对当今的父母来说是一个重要的信息，因为有海量的信息。对我来说，试图成为一个好父母感觉像是一种重担。似乎标准已经被设定为完美，或者至少是所谓的“有效”，而我们想写一本书，以更全面的方式描述
what it means to be a parent that's going to do what matters most and not where you're out in the process or not become a hyper-hover parent as well. Yeah. I think when we were talking about this and trying to decide on this title as well, you know, I have four young kids and one of the things that I've been involved in, I have, there's a group of a few mothers that graduated from my PhD program and we all sort of lean on each other for parenting advice, if you will. And what ends up happening, what I've realized is a lot of what can be consumed about parenting is sets the bar really high to the point of if I do something wrong, what does that mean for my child? My child is going to fail in life. And this, I've noticed,
作为一个父母意味着什么，去做最重要的事情，而不是在过程中不知所措，或者也不会变成一个过度监视的“直升机父母”。是的。我想当我们谈论这个并试图决定这个书名时，你知道的，我有四个幼儿，我参与的事情之一是，我有一个由几个从我的博士项目毕业的母亲组成的小组，如果可以的话，我们都会互相依靠对方寻求育儿建议。最终发生的情况是，我意识到关于育儿可以吸收的大量内容，把标准设得非常高，以至于如果我做错了什么，那对我的孩子意味着什么？我的孩子在生活中会失败。我注意到，
has created a really high amount of anxiety for new parents in this generation. And I think it has really helped to talk to them and sort of bounce ideas off of each other, but also recognize that some of the things that we say are, you know, really important. Like, you know, how does my kid look today? Or maybe did I not handle this situation exactly right? Comes down to, well, sometimes it's okay to just be good enough. Because if we worry too much about all of the fine details, kind of like what Tim was talking about is we miss the larger picture of what it means to be a parent and what it means to run a family. And so good enough, I think is often now the advice that parents need more than ever because they're told so many things about you have to be this way and a perfect parent looks like this and it's just too much. It's too much to manage.
这给这一代的新父母带来了极高的焦虑。而且我认为，与他们交谈并互相交流想法确实很有帮助，同时也要认识到我们所说的一些事情，你知道的，真的很重要。比如，你知道的，我孩子今天看起来怎么样？或者也许我没有完全正确地处理这种情况？归根结底，有时候，只要足够好就可以了。因为如果我们对所有的细节过于担心，有点像蒂姆所说的，我们就忽略了成为父母意味着什么以及经营一个家庭意味着什么的宏观画面。因此，我认为足够好现在往往是父母比以往任何时候都更需要的建议，因为他们被告知了太多关于“你必须这样，完美的父母看起来是这样的”的事情，这实在是太多了。这太难以应付了。
Can I add to that? Because I agree wholeheartedly with what Lauren said. And I think our book aims for a sweet spot between, you know, there's one kind of parenting book that's a rather foxy, homespun approach to parenting. It's more of a literary work than a reflection of the science of parenting. Then there are those books that are drawn tightly from the science of parenting. But those can get rather prescriptive and exacting. and we were, our book I think is aimed sort of between the two at a sweet spot, which says,
我能补充一点吗？因为我完全同意劳伦所说的话。我认为我们的书旨在寻找一个甜蜜点，你知道的，有一种育儿书是一种相当古怪、质朴的育儿方法。与其说是对育儿科学的反映，不如说它更像是一部文学作品。然后还有那些紧密汲取育儿科学的书籍。但那些书可能会变得相当规范和苛刻。而我们的书，我认为介于两者之间，找到了一个甜蜜点，它说的是，
let's build from, let's draw from the science of parenting, but let's render it in a way that's user friendly, that's parent friendly, that's digestible, and that distills the, the, the key findings down to an essential whole, to what matters most. Does the good enough approach in effect also extend to the kids because, you know, there's so much pressure on our children these days to be absolutely perfect and spectacular. So if you're good enough parent, well, maybe you can be a good enough son or daughter as well. Absolutely. I think sometimes people don't realize that when you set standards really high for yourself or for your child, like I want my child to be the greatest athlete there ever was. right and now I know what it means that means they need to be involved in three sports that take up all their time and the AP classes they need to be involved in all of those because my child's going to be the best and what ends up happening is the child gets burnt out the parent can get burnt out and when you base your family and your relationship off of those accomplishments rather than the relationship you actually have with one another
让我们建立在育儿科学的基础之上，让我们以用户友好、父母友好、易于消化并将其关键发现提炼为一个必不可少的整体、提炼到最重要的事情上的方式来呈现它。“足够好”的方法实际上是否也延伸到了孩子身上？因为，你知道的，这些日子我们的孩子承受着巨大的压力，要绝对完美和壮观。所以如果你是一个足够好的父母，嗯，也许你也可以是一个足够好的儿子或女儿。绝对的。我想有时人们没有意识到，当你为自己或你的孩子设定非常高的标准时，比如我希望我的孩子成为有史以来最伟大的运动员，对吧，现在我知道这意味着什么，这意味着他们需要参加占用他们所有时间的三个运动项目，他们需要参加所有那些AP（大学先修）课程，因为我的孩子将成为最好的，而最终发生的情况是，孩子精疲力竭，父母也会精疲力竭，当你把你的家庭和关系建立在这些成就之上，而不是你们彼此实际拥有的关系上时，
you lose something in there. And that can cause more distress rather than just focusing on, again, what matters most, the good enough. Yeah. I think it's been way overstated that our parenting shapes our children and their personality and their future. There are a lot of other factors besides parenting practices that shape who children become. and more recent research speaks loudly to that. And as a parent, my tendency is to adopt a posture of discovery. Let me discover who my children will become.
你在其中失去了一些东西。这可能会导致更多的痛苦，而不是仅仅专注于，再次强调，最重要的事情，即“足够好”。是的。我认为我们的育儿方式塑造了我们的孩子、他们的性格和他们的未来，这种说法被大大夸大了。除了育儿实践之外，还有许多其他因素塑造了孩子们成为什么样的人。最近的研究强烈地支持了这一点。作为父母，我的倾向是采取一种发现的姿态。让我去发现我的孩子们将成为什么样的人。
And let me be ready to love and accept them when I discover who they are. But the notion that I'm exercising my preferences and shaping who they are and who they become is both mythical and dangerous. So it's an interesting posture to adopt, but I think it's a healthy one. Let me learn who my child is. Let me learn who my child will become. And let me practice accepting who that child is and conveying a message of love and belonging. That's a different way to go about the task of parenting.
当我发现他们是谁时，让我准备好去爱他们并接受他们。但我正在行使自己的偏好并塑造他们是谁以及他们将成为什么样的人这一概念既是神话又是危险的。所以这是一个有趣的姿态，但我认为这是一个健康的姿态。让我了解我的孩子是谁。让我了解我的孩子将成为什么样的人。让我练习接受那个孩子是谁，并传达爱与归属的信息。这是进行育儿工作的一种不同方式。
And I think that that segues into the question that I had where you write about the most important job that parents have is to build a relationship with their children. And I think that might surprise some people maybe who don't think that they need to build a relationship because they have a relationship. But what do you mean? What is the special approach that you recommend that might not be immediately evident to a harried mother or father? So I believe that we've got core components that we highlight within this book. There are three aspects that we believe are really important for a relationship between a parent and a child. And then we also have some components that we feel are sort of the foundations of those things too.
我认为这顺理成章地引出了我的问题，你在书中写到，父母最重要的工作是与孩子建立关系。我认为这可能会让一些人感到惊讶，他们可能认为自己不需要建立关系，因为他们已经有了关系。但你们是什么意思呢？你们推荐的这种特殊方法可能不会立刻对一个筋疲力尽的母亲或父亲显而易见？所以我相信我们在本书中强调了一些核心组成部分。我们认为有三个方面对父母和孩子之间的关系非常重要。然后我们还有一些我们认为也是这些事情的基础的组成部分。
So largely when we're thinking about a relationship, which Tim alluded to already previously, was this posture of acceptance. So when we think about our relationship with our child, we're really saying, I see you and I accept who you are for who you are, right? So I have four little children and I may parent them pretty similarly. You know, they're all close and age together as well. And they are different. They're different people. They have different interests. They have different inclinations.
所以很大程度上，当我们考虑关系时，蒂姆之前已经暗示过，就是这种接受的姿态。因此，当我们考虑与孩子关系时，我们实际上是在说，我看到你，我接受你是谁，因为你就是你，对吧？所以我四个小孩子，我对他们的育儿方式可能相当相似。你知道的，他们的年龄也很接近。但他们是不同的。他们是不同的人。他们有不同的兴趣。他们有不同的倾向。
They have different temperaments. And so part of being a parent then is first saying, I see that you are who you are and I'm okay with that. And that can look in many different ways. It can be very outward in the way that we express that. And it can also be more silent in the way that we express that too. So sometimes not saying anything and rather than correcting your child all the time. The second component of that then is containing. So thinking about our job as a parent is also to recognize that we, you know, children are impulsive sometimes.
他们有不同的气质。因此，作为父母的一部分，首先要说的是，我看到你是谁，我对此没意见。这可以有许多不同的表现方式。在我们表达这一点的方式上，它可以是非常外显的。在我们表达这一点的方式上，它也可以是更无声的。所以有时什么都不说，而不是一直纠正你的孩子。那么，这第二个组成部分就是包容（containing）。因此，思考我们作为父母的工作也是要认识到，我们，你知道的，孩子们有时很冲动。
We still have to welcome them into the culture and society. in which we live and tell them what is and is not acceptable. And so our practices of containment sort of help us do that. And then the last component within that is being a leader and your leadership within the family. So outwardly expressing what it means to be a good person, talking about what our values are within a family, and then sharing that with our children too. there's more to that and I'll let Tim take over. Yeah.
我们仍然必须欢迎他们融入我们所生活的文化和社会，并告诉他们什么是可以接受的，什么是不可以接受的。因此，我们的包容实践在某种程度上帮助我们做到这一点。然后其中的最后一个组成部分是成为一名领导者以及你在家庭中的领导力。在外部表达成为一个好人的意义，谈论我们在家庭中的价值观，然后也与我们的孩子们分享这些。还有更多内容，我让蒂姆接手。是的。
I think if we zoom back a little bit, I think there needs to be an appreciation that we have cast, we being mainly professionals like Lauren and I, have tended to cast parenting as something set apart from relationships. There are some parenting advice that's like an itemized list of if your child does X, you should do Y. If your child has this problem or engages in this behavior and this is how you should respond without appreciating the context of the relationship in which those events occur, you know,
我想如果我们把镜头稍微拉远一点，我认为需要有一种认识，即我们已经把育儿——我们主要是指像劳伦和我这样的专业人士——倾向于把育儿描绘成独立于关系之外的事情。有些育儿建议就像是一份分条列出的清单，如果你的孩子做了X，你就应该做Y。如果你的孩子有这个问题或从事这种行为，这就是你应该如何回应的，而没有欣赏这些事件发生的关系的背景，你知道的，
depending on how strong or strained the relationship is, you might want to do very different things because at the end of the day, it's the relationship that will move your child toward being a good, healthy citizen. And I tend to say it this way, Kim, if there was some farcical choice, I had to make between two surrogate parents, one who was very good at relationships in his or her life, and one who knew a lot about parenting, I would choose the one who was good at relationships, okay? Because that's what it is. But too often, I think because of people like us throwing out so much advice, folks become parents and they move into this mode where they sort of jettison what they think about in terms of how to make a relationship work. None of the
根据关系的牢固或紧张程度，你可能会想做非常不同事情，因为归根结底，是这种关系会促使你的孩子成为一个优秀、健康的公民。我倾向于这样说，金，如果必须在两个代孕父母之间做出某种荒谬的选择，一个是非常擅长生活中的人际关系，另一个是对育儿了解很多，我会选择那个擅长人际关系的人，好吧？因为这就是关系的本质。但太 vaak（荷兰语，这里指通常），我想由于像我们这样的人抛出了太多的建议，人们成为父母后，他们进入了一种模式，在这种模式中，他们抛弃了关于如何让关系运作的想法。我们拥有的任何关系都不应该涉及被 victimized（受害）、被利用、被虐待。我们拥有的任何关系都不应该涉及不去向我们所爱和关心的人传达接受的信息。我们拥有的任何关系都不应该涉及放弃我们的核心价值观以及我们的行为方式。因此，你想把所有这些关系组成部分带到亲子关系中，不仅仅是因为它是亲子关系，而是因为这就是拥有健康关系的意义所在。是的，在书的开始，你要求父母思考他们的育儿目标，这与他们对孩子未来的目标可能并不相同。
relationships we have should involve being victimized, taking advantage of being abused. None of the relationships we have should involve not trying to convey a message of acceptance to the people we love and care about. And none of the relationships we have should involve abandoning what our core values are, how we carry ourselves. So you want to bring all those relationship components to the parent-child relationship, not just because it's a parent-child relationship because that's what it means to have a healthy relationship. Yeah, at the beginning of the book, you asked parents to think about their parenting goals, which are not the same as the goals that they might have for their children's future.
当你谈论育儿目标时，你是什么意思？父母应该如何设定这些目标，以及他们如何才能坚持这些目标？这是一个很好的问题。我们将育儿目标描述为父母指导其育儿行为的目标。但这很少是一个讨论的话题。你的育儿目标是什么？我们往往从我们对孩子未来的期望来考虑它。但如果你，一个父母，一个工作的父母，你那天晚上回家，你心里作为一个父母有一些目标。
What do you mean when you talk about parenting goals? How should parents set them and how can they stick to them? That's a great question. We describe parenting goals as the goals parents have for guiding their parenting behavior. But it's seldom a topic of discussion. What are your parenting goals? We tend to think of it in terms of what we want for our children downstream. But if you, a parent, a working parent, you go home that evening, you have some goals in mind as a parent.
通常它们是隐藏的，也许嵌入在对孩子的自动反应中。事情变得有点无意识和例行公事。在我们与孩子的这些互动中，我们可能没有向前看，也没有意识到我们在试图做什么。如果在拥有一个让孩子感到被接纳的关系中存在价值，他们会定期被包容。换句话说，有一个“这你不能做”的信息。并且父母以一种体现良好价值观的方式表现自己，那么这些就是指导育儿行为的伟大目标。现在，你会立即知道孩子们功能方面的结果吗？不，这就像一个计划。
Oftentimes they're sort of hidden and maybe embedded in automatic reactions to children. Things become sort of mindless and routine. And we may not be forward thinking or conscious about what are we trying to do in these interactions I have with my child. And if there's value in having a relationship where children feel accepted, they are periodically contained. In other words, there's a message of this you cannot do. And the parent is carrying himself or herself in a way that espouses good values, then those are great goals to guide parenting behavior. Now, will you know the outcome immediately in terms of your children's functioning? No, it's like a plan.
这需要时间来展现。因此，育儿行为的目标更接近于我们在任何特定的一天或情况下所做的事情。不仅如此，当我们自动行事时，我们可能会在那种关系中对自己造成伤害。因此，把我们的目标仅仅看作是与孩子建立更强大的关系，而不是担心他们会成为谁，或者他们是否是班上最聪明的孩子？他们是最好的运动员吗？他们穿得最好吗？他们会成为，你知道的，X、Y和Z吗？这可能会突然成为一个你没有想到的自动目标，在这个目标中，你对孩子尖酸刻薄，或者你告诉他们需要做什么。有时这会迫使你表态：我要推得多紧？如果我的孩子现在没有做我想让他们做的事，我可能在推行一个我甚至没有意识到的议程，而这是以我和孩子之间的关系为代价的。所以如果我的目标是——也许我现在正在努力处理与孩子之间的关系。所以如果我的目标，如果我有意识地，我在乎我的孩子感到被爱，并希望他们也爱我。
It takes time for that to unfold. So the parents, the goals for parenting behavior are more proximal to what we do in any given day or situation. And to add on that, too, when we act automatically, we may be doing ourselves harm in that relationship. And so thinking about our goal as just having a stronger relationship with our child rather than worrying about who they're going to be or are they the smartest kid in the class? Are they the best athlete? Are they the best dressed? Are they going to be, you know, X, Y, and Z? That may snap in as an automatic goal that you're not thinking about where you're snarky with your kid or you're telling them what they need to be doing. And that sort of forces your hand sometimes to say, how hard am I going to push? If my kid isn't doing what I want them to do right now, I may be pushing an agenda I'm not even aware of, at the expense of the relationship that I have with my child. And so if my goal is maybe I'm struggling with the relationship with my child right now. So if my goal, if I'm conscious about, I care about my child feeling loved and wanting them to love me back too.
显然，你不能以这种方式强迫你的孩子做任何事。你不能强迫他们爱你。然而，如果你有“我希望我们一起变得更强大”的目标，并且你对此更有深思熟虑，这会改变你在某一时刻的行动方式。因此，清理地板或纠正他们顶嘴的语气，如果我们在那一刻凭本能思考，可能会觉得这是最重要的事情。但如果我们说我的关系是最重要的，我们在一起的关系是最重要的事情。那么也许你会放过其中一些事情。而这实际上最终会使这种关系变得更牢固。是的，这需要有意的、深思熟虑的和明确的理由，说明你作为一个父母为什么要这样做，
Obviously, you can't make your child do anything in that way. You can't force them to love you. And yet if you have that goal of I want us to be stronger together and you're more thoughtful about it, that can change how you act in a moment. And so cleaning up the floor or addressing the tone in which they spoke back to you may seem like that's the most important thing if we're thinking automatically in that moment. But if we say my relationship is the most important, our relationship together is the most important. Then maybe you let some of those things go. and that actually ends up building that relationship stronger. Yeah, it's being intentional, deliberate, and explicit with why you're doing what you're doing as a parent,
而不是出于某种隐藏的情感目标（比如我很沮丧或我很累）或出于通过孩子过着代入式生活的某种偏好做出反应。我们向父母建议，你知道的，需要记住的有用目标，或者是传达接纳的信息，传达包容的信息（即有些事情你不能做），然后传达关于我们的家庭价值观、我们的信仰以及我们珍视之物的信息。那么，让我承接你刚才所说的话，因为你谈到的是包容而不是纪律。
as opposed to reacting out of some hidden emotional goal, like I'm frustrated or I'm tired, or out of some preference to live vicariously through your child. And we offer to parents that, you know, useful goals to keep in mind, or conveying a message of acceptance, conveying a message of containment that there are some things you cannot do, and then conveying a message of what our family values, what we believe in and hold dear. So let me pick up from what you've just said, because you're talking about containment rather than discipline.
在书中，你提供了一条经验法则。你称之为80-20法则。那是什么，它是如何运作的？所以我们提出了一个挑衅性的观点：有效的纪律是有选择性的纪律。好吧。现在，关于杰瑞·帕特森（Jerry Patterson）和俄勒冈社会学习中心的同事们过去称之为针对行为具有破坏性和反抗性儿童的“不当纪律”，有大量的科学研究。
And in the book, you offer a rule of thumb. You call it the 80-20 rule. What is that and how does that work? So we make the provocative point that effective discipline is selective discipline. Okay. Now, there's a lot of science on inept what Jerry Patterson and colleagues at Oregon Social Learning Center used to call inept discipline with children whose behavior was disruptive and defiant.
在这些父母身上观察到的模式有两种，要么是相当严厉和过度惩罚，要么是相当松懈和纵容，好吧，这与鲍姆林（Baumrind）的区分非常相似。所以，如果你是一个在控制孩子行为方面遇到困难的父母，那么你在纵容和严厉、严厉和纵容之间摇摆不定也是合乎情理的。因此，可以通过明确以下问题来加以应对：哪些是最重要的事情？在作为纪律执行者方面，你希望在哪些事情上保持一致？哪些事情你可以放手？
And the pattern that was observed in these parents was of two sorts, either being quite harsh and overly punitive are being quite lax and permissive, okay, not unlike, you know, Balmran's distinction. So, and it makes sense if you're a parent who's having trouble controlling your child's behavior, then you might wax and weighing between being permissive and harsh, harsh and permissive. And so it can be countered by having clarity about, well, what are the things that matter most? What are the things that you want to be consistent on in terms of being a disciplinarian. And what things do you let go?
金，育儿文献中有时会这样说：明智地选择你的战斗，对吧？这是一个非常常用的短语。里面有“战斗”这个词有点不幸。尽管如此，关于明智选择的观点是有充分依据的。但人们并不经常讨论它。嗯，那是什么意思，你知道，明智地选择你的战斗？嗯，我们认为育儿科学在发展心理学中为我们指明了方向。
Sometimes it's said in the parenting literature, Kim, is choose your battles wisely, right? It's a very common phrase. It's a bit unfortunate that the word battle is in there. But nonetheless, the point about choosing wisely is well, well-founded. But it's not often talked about it. well, what does that mean, you know, choose your battle wisely? Well, we think that the science of parenting points us in a direction there in the developmental psychology.
对儿童发展最具破坏性的行为之一是他们对强制（coercion）的使用，这是一个广泛的术语，用于定义各种形式的攻击性、对抗性或威胁性行为。好吧。学会使用强制、攻击和其他形式对抗性行为的儿童在未来的许多问题上面临风险。辍学、违法、物质使用，诸如此类。因此，显然这是一个最重要、关系重大的类别。因此，如果你在寻找把时间和精力放在哪里的地方，把时间和精力放在限制孩子使用强制和攻击上是有道理的。
One of the behaviors that is most problematic for children's development is their use of coercion, which is a broad term used to define various forms of aggression or antagonistic or threatening behavior. Okay. Children who learn to use coercion, aggression, and other sorts of antagonistic behavior are at risk for a lot of problems downstream. School dropout, delinquency, substance use, things like that. And so clearly this is a category that matters most, that matters a lot. So if you're looking for where to put your time and energy, it makes sense to put your time and energy on limiting your child's use of coercion and aggression.
现在，还有一大堆对儿童发展关系不大的事情。我想我们在书中举了一个吃培根的例子。如果你的女儿在吃培根，而且只吃培根呢？而且这种行为一直持续。你说，嗯，你得吃点别的。而她吃的全部都是这个。那么吃培根在什么时候会演变成一个严重的问题？可能需要一段时间这才会成为一个严重的问题，或者挖鼻孔之类的。
Now, there are a whole host of other things that matter little to children's development. I think we give an example in the book of bacon eating. What if your daughter was eating bacon and only bacon? And just it persisted. And you said, well, you've got to eat something else. And that's all she ate. So at what point does bacon eating rise to a significant problem? It might take a while before that's a significant problem or nose speaking or whatever.
有许多作为父母我们可能希望孩子不要做的事情，我们可能会觉得恶心，或者你知道的，难看，或者它可能会很烦人，但这与说“这种行为如果重复具有发展意义”是非常不同的。需要注意的这类事情并不多，但对于那些确实需要的，你真的想去关注它们，而且——这就是关键所在——如果你去抓，比方说假设有20种不同的行为，其中只有两种是有关系的。而你将分散你的纪律和包容的努力，并且很可能会失败。因此，你实际上稀释了你的权威。你稀释了孩子们将你视为权威人物的程度，因为
there's a lot of things that we as parents can prefer that our children not do that we don't we find maybe disgusting or you know unsightly or that it might be annoying but that's very different than saying this behavior if repeated has developmental significance there are not many of those to pay attention to but the ones that are you really want to pay attention to and and here's the kicker if you're going after let's say hypothetically, 20 different behaviors, only two of which matter. And you're going to be spreading thin your efforts to discipline and contain and likely fail. And so you actually dilute your authority. You dilute the degree to which children see you as a person of authority because
你没有发挥作用，而且因为你试图做的事情太多了。好吧。因此，你希望将你的包容努力保留用于最重要的事情。我们实际上，我的一些研究着眼于儿童的信念，即父母和老师在发生冲突和目标冲突时是否能够包容他们。我们有一个测量指标，其中的一个项目类似于：你想去外面玩。你妈妈说你不能去外面玩。她能让你呆在里面吗？所以这是一项努力去探究。
you're not being effective and because you're trying to do too much. Okay. And so you want to preserve your efforts at containment for things that matter most. We actually, some of my research looked at children's beliefs about whether parents and teachers can contain them if there's a conflict and goals. We had a measure in one of the items was something like, you want to go play outside. Your mom says you can't go play outside. Can she make you stay inside? So it's an effort to get it.
孩子们是否相信成年人负责？嗯，果不其然，大多数孩子都说是他们负责，但对于那些对此怀疑的孩子，对于那些包容感较低的孩子，无论父母的纪律有多好，他们都有很高水平的问题行为。因此，如果孩子们秉持着“我能智胜你（你知道的，来个180度大转弯，我能绕过你）”的信念运作，如果他们怀疑你的权威地位，那可不好。因此，你想通过使用有选择性的纪律来保护和维护你的权威地位。这样做带来的另一个好处是，你减少了互动中充满消极情绪的场合。因为纪律往往涉及负面情绪、令人不快的遭遇。因此，如果你减少了试图管教孩子以包容孩子、并且存在负面情绪的场合，那么会发生什么呢？你的关系就会是积极的而非消极的。同样，有相当一致的研究表明，积极或中性交流与消极交流的比例为80%或大约4比1，
Do children believe that adults are in charge? well lo and behold most kids say yes they're in charge but for the kids who doubt that for the kids who have a low sense of containment they had high levels of problem behavior regardless of how well parents discipline so if children are operating from a belief that i can outwit you you know do a turnaround and i can work around you if they doubt your position of authority that's not good and so you want to protect and preserve your position of authority through the use of selective discipline The other win that comes from that is that you reduce the number of occasions where the interactions are emotionally negative. Because discipline can often involve negative emotionality, unpleasant encounters. So if you reduce the occasions where you're trying to discipline your child to contain your child where there's negative emotions, then guess what happens? Your relationship is more positive than negative. And again, there's pretty consistent research that shows that an 80% are about 4 to 1.
这标志着一段令人满意、稳定的关系。如果你是一个达到50%的父母，一半时间是消极的，一半时间是积极的，那可不好。好吧。因此，目标将是有点像用你的直觉作为晴雨表，来看看我与孩子关系进展得如何？我的互动中是否至少有80%或接近这个比例是
ratio of positive or neutral exchanges to negative exchanges is signals a satisfying, stable relationship. If you're a parent who's 50 at 50%, half the time it's negative, half the time it's positive, that's not good. Okay. And so the goal would be to kind of use your gut as a barometer of how is my relationship with my child going? Am I experiencing at least 80% or close to it of my interactions as,
中性的或积极的？中性是其中关键的部分。是的。或者它就像抛硬币？就像我永远不知道我们什么时候会回到关系的红色警戒状态。对。蒂姆，你讲得太美妙了。而且我认为通常当我们给出这个数字时，你知道的，它已经变成了，它可以是4比1，对吧，这些事情也在发生。
neutral or positive? And neutral is the key part of that. Yeah. Or is it like a coin flip? Like I never know when we're going to be back in the relationship red. Right. And that was beautifully said, Tim. And I think often when we give that figure, you know, it's gone from, it can be four to one, right, that these things are happening as well.
但我认为人们会惊慌失措，因为他们说，我怎么能，你知道的，在一个美国社会里，我们就像是，你必须快乐，那是事情运作良好的迹象，对吧？我认为当我们开始提供“嗯，你知道的，大多数时候事情应该是快乐的”这一背景时，我认为这也设定了不切实际的期望。因此，其中重要的部分是“中性”，中性或积极，这与消极形成鲜明对比。因此，如果你注意到大部分时间甚至一半时间你都在与孩子争吵，或者你的孩子对你感到沮丧和生气，那么这通常就是一个问题。但如果是中性的，中性可以是当我给孩子某种东西时，他们对我发牢骚，对吧？我们可以忽略这一点。
But I think people freak out because they say, how am I supposed to, you know, in a society, an American society where we're like, you got to be. happy and that's a sign of things working well, right? I think when we start providing the context of well, you know, most of the time things should be happy, then I think that also sets up unrealistic expectations. So the important component of that is neutral, neutral or positive, and so that is in direct contrast with negative. So if you're noticing that the most of the time or even half of the time you're getting into spats or your child is getting, frustrated with you and angry with you, then that is usually a problem. But if it's neutral, neutral can be my kid just whined at me when I gave them something, right? We can ignore that.
这里的想法是我们专注于什么，我们在乎什么？所以蒂姆刚才也谈到了，你知道的，当存在强制行为时，可能是说谎、偷窃，诸如此类的事情。这些确实会导致以后那些问题行为，并且更令人担忧，正如我们所看到的，这些就是我们所说的，你必须把屁股从沙发上抬起来（应对）的事情，对吧？这些是我们不能忽视的事情。这些是我们必须挺身而出、必须去处理那种令人沮丧的对抗的事情。对于小孩子来说，就是，你知道的，他们发脾气，他们变得非常愤怒。
The idea is what do we focus on and what do we care about? And so Tim also was talking about, you know, when there's coercion, it could be lying, stealing, things. things that do lead to those problem behaviors later on and are more concerning, as we've seen, those are the things that we call, you know, you have to get your butt off the couch for, right? Those are the things we don't ignore. Those are the things we have to stand up and we have to deal with that frustrating confrontation potentially. For young kids, it's, you know, they throw tantrums, they get really angry.
我对这一点再清楚不过了。认识到这些事情很重要。有些事情根本不值得花时间和精力，因为它确实牺牲了你与孩子之间的关系。所以我喜欢我的孩子对我翻白眼，或者用发牢骚的声音说话，或者我刚做好晚饭，结果“呃，妈妈，真恶心”？
I know that all too well. and recognizing those things are important. And some things just aren't worth the time or the energy because it does sacrifice that relationship that what you have with your child. So do I like that my child rolled their eyes at me or was used a whiny voice or I just cooked dinner and know, ugh, mom, that's gross.
这种情况经常遇到。有时这不值得去争吵，对吧？你放手吧。你让它过去。为了关系的利益，这样做是值得的。除此之外的一个额外成分是，你知道的，当你有一个表现非常好的孩子时，对吧？所以他们不撒谎。他们不与人发生肢体冲突。你可以专注于一些较小的事情。你知道的，如果你的孩子听你的话，我不知道，平均而言，小孩子十次里会有六次听话，非常小的孩子，对吧？如果他们十次里有六次听话，那已经很不错了。通常当有行为问题的孩子来找我时，我们看到的是十次里零次，十次里两次，对吧？如果你有非常听话的孩子，那么你就可以，你知道的，你可以开始强制执行一些其他与孩子关系更困难的父母所不能做的事情。
Get that a lot. Sometimes it's not worth fighting about, Right? You let it go. You let it slide. And it's to the benefit of the relationship because of that. And an additional component to that is, you know, when you have a child that is really well behaving, right? So they're not lying. They're not getting into physical altercations with people. You can focus on some of that smaller stuff. You know, if your kid listens to you, I don't know, young kids on average, will listen six out of ten times, really little kids, right? That's pretty good if they're listening six out of ten times. And often when kids come in that I've seen that have behavior problems, we're seeing zero out of ten times, two out of ten times, right? And if you've got kids that are really pretty compliant, then you can, you know, you can start enforcing some things that maybe other parents that have a more difficult relationship with their child can. not. So, hey, I told you, you know, every time you leave a room, turn off the lights, or we have this
不能做的事。所以，嘿，我告诉过你，你知道的，每次你离开房间时，把灯关掉，或者我们有这个规则，把鞋子放在前门旁。好吧。如果你的孩子是一个大体快乐的孩子，而且你们的关系没有持续紧张，他们也没有殴打其他孩子和说谎，那么这些就是你可以关注的事情。但是，如果你有一个与你关系非常糟糕的孩子，他们在说谎，他们卷入了许多争吵，有很多语言问题发生，他们对你尖叫。那种强制执行，那些小事情是我们应该忽略的。所以这是一个分层系统。我们在书中对此进行了更多的讨论。我认为你谈到了有意识的育儿和无意识的育儿，我想谈谈这两者之间的区别？因为我认为你谈到的一些事情需要一定程度的正念。
rule where you put your shoes by the front door. Okay. If your kid is a generally happy kid and your relationship is not continuously strained and they're not beating other kids up and lying, then those are the things you can focus on. But if you've got a kid that you're having a really hard relationship with and they are lying, they are getting into a lot of fights. There's a lot of verbal issues going on where they're screaming at you. Those types of enforcement, those little things are what we should ignore. So it's a tiered system. And we talk about that more in the book, too. I think that you talk about mindful and mindless parenting. And I wanted to talk about the differences between the two? Because I think that some of what you're talking about requires a level of mindfulness.
但无意识的育儿也有其作用。而且正如你所说，这不是因为父母不插手或者无能。但这两种做法的一些例子是什么，父母如何利用这些技巧来为自己谋取优势？所以我们使用“无意识（mindless）”这个词并不是指某人愚蠢或不明智。它意味着一种精神状态，在这种状态下，你以自动的、过度学习的自动方式运作，所以你对自己在做什么并不是深思熟虑和有意识的。另一方面，正念育儿（mindful parenting）涉及对你要做什么做出更有意识、深思熟虑、付诸努力的决定。我们无法24/7都以这种方式运作。这是不可能的，无论是对父母还是对任何人。
But mindless parenting also has a role. And I think, as you say, it's not because the parent is unplugged or inept. But what are some examples of the two and how can parents use those techniques to their advantage? So we don't use the word mindless to mean that someone's being stupid or unwise. It's meant to imply a mental state in which you're operating on automatic, in an overlearned automatic way, so you're not deliberate and conscious about what you're doing. Mindful parenting, on the other hand, it involves a much more conscious, deliberate, effortful decision about what you're going to do. We can't operate that way 24-7. It's impossible, whether it's a parent or anyone.
但你有时可以进入这种模式。危险在于没有意识到你的一些育儿方式相当无意识、自动且经过过度学习。因此，如果你发现自己总是陷入与孩子对立的同一种旧动力中，并且你们两个都愤怒、沮丧、悲伤和受伤，那么你可能需要考虑这样一种可能性，即你的育儿方式中存在一些自动的、过度学习的方面。当你开始与孩子接触或互动时，关注你的感受、体验和想法是什么，这将是很重要的。因此，我们的书中有一整章专门讨论健康。
But you can move into that mode at times. The danger is not appreciating that some of your parenting is rather mindless, automatic and overlearned. And so if you keep finding yourself stuck in the same old dynamic of getting crossways with your child and you're both angry and frustrated and sad and hurt, then you might want to consider the possibility that there's some automatic overlearn aspects to your parenting. and it would be important to attend to what it is that you're feeling, experiencing, and thinking as you begin to engage or interact with your child. So we have an entire chapter in our book devoted to health.
我们认为这是育儿中不可或缺的一个要素，即父母的健康。其中很大一部分是情绪健康。过去二十年的研究非常有说服力地证明，管理我们的情绪健康要求我们能够暂停。我们可以在心理上按下暂停键，关注内部发生的事情——我们在想什么，我们在感觉到什么——而不是以一种自动的、过度学习的方式相当迅速地做出反应，以摆脱我们感受到的任何不愉快。大多数人以那种自动的、过度学习的方式从头脑向下应对。我们建议的应对方式，我们称之为从地面向上（from the ground up），在当下脚踏实地。
We see it as an essential ingredient in parenting, parents' health. And much of that is emotional health. And research in the last two decades has spoken very robustly to the fact that managing our emotional health requires that we can pause. We can hit the pause button psychologically and attend to what's happening inside what we're thinking, what we're feeling, as opposed to reacting rather quickly in an automatic-overlearned way to get rid of whatever unpleasantness we're feeling. Most people cope from the head down in that automatic overlearned way. And we recommend coping, we call it from the ground up, getting grounded in the present moment,
我们将其视为育儿和父母健康中必不可少的一个要素。其中很大一部分是情绪健康。过去二十年的研究强有力地表明，管理我们的情绪健康需要我们能够暂停。我们可以在心理上按下暂停键，关注内心正在发生的事情——我们在想什么，我们在感受什么，而不是以一种自动且过度习得的方式做出相当迅速的反应，以摆脱我们感受到的任何不快。大多数人都是以那种自动且过度习得的方式从头脑向下进行应对。我们建议的应对方式，我们称之为从基础做起，立足于当下，
paying attention to what you're feeling, and then going to the head with a wise plan. So it's about being aware of, you know, awarenessing as Cabin Zen, the person who brought mindfulness into health care would say my awareness thing is biggest than thinking because it subsumes thinking. But a lot of parents don't practice being aware in a zoomed about. fashion of what they're doing. So none of this happens without practice, by the way. So you can't just decide one day to be a mindful parent. It requires that you practice pausing, being in the moment, and leaning into what you're feeling. And we spend an entire chapter unpacking that. Both of you work with kids who have serious behavior issues in your research and in your
关注你的感受，然后用明智的计划去思考。因此，正如将正念引入医疗保健的卡巴金（Cabin Zen）所说的那样，这是关于培养觉察，他说我的觉察比思考更宏大，因为它包含了思考。但是，许多父母并没有以全面审视的方式去练习觉察自己在做什么。顺便说一句，这些都不是不练就能实现的。所以你不能仅仅在某一天决定成为一个有正念的父母。它需要你练习停下来，活在当下，并深入体会你的感受。我们在整整一章中详细探讨了这一点。你们俩在研究和临床工作中都接触过有严重行为问题的儿童
clinical work. Is your advice different for those parents than it is for dealing with run-of-the-mill everyday problems or does the same type of advice apply across the board for all types of families and situations? Dr. Quetch, maybe you could answer first based on your work with disruptive children and those who have autism spectrum disorder. A lot to unpack there, I think, because historically, a lot of the evidence-based treatments that we use to work with families to address disruptive behaviors assumes a lack of skill on the parents' side. So often you will go to a treatment for your child who is experiencing disruptive behaviors and you'll go essentially so that a therapist can teach you possibly what you're missing. It's assumed then my child is misbehaving because of some sort of deficit
工作。对于这些父母，你们的建议是否不同于处理日常普通问题的方法，还是说同类型的建议适用于所有类型的家庭和情况？奎奇博士，也许你可以根据你对具有破坏性行为的儿童以及自闭症谱系障碍儿童的研究率先回答。我认为这里有很多内容需要剖析，因为从历史上看，我们用来与家庭合作解决破坏性行为的许多循证治疗，都假设父母一方缺乏技能。因此，当你为有破坏性行为的孩子寻求治疗时，你通常会去，这样治疗师可能会教你你所缺少的东西。这就假定，我的孩子行为不端是因为某种缺陷
within the parent. So bad behavior on the child part is sometimes assumed bad parenting, right? And we try to challenge that myth in a way because we say you can have skills and there may be other things getting in the way of you being able to connect with your child in a meaningful way.
存在于父母身上。因此，孩子的不良行为有时被认为是父母管教不善，对吧？我们试图在某种程度上挑战这种神话，因为我们说你可以拥有技能，但可能还有其他事情阻碍了你以有意义的方式与孩子建立联系。
So when working with parents of autistic kids, you know, a lot of these parents do have great skills and they are challenged because they have a neurodivergent child. They don't understand how their child experiences the world. And if they're neurotypical themselves, they think, well, when a child screams and throws a fit, that means they're being defiant, right? And therefore, I will. approach my child as if they're being defiant and I handle it by providing, you know, there's a sanction or I put them in time out or I, you know, have privileges removed. But it's different because sometimes a child is not tantruming because you've told them no, but instead they're having a
因此，在与自闭症儿童的父母合作时，你知道，其中许多父母确实拥有出色的技能，他们面临挑战是因为他们有一个神经多样性的孩子。他们不了解他们的孩子是如何体验世界的。如果他们自己是神经典型者，他们会认为，当一个孩子尖叫并大发雷霆时，这意味着他们在挑衅，对吧？因此，我将把我的孩子当作他们在挑衅来对待，我通过提供制裁、让他们面壁思过、或者取消特权来处理。但这是不同的，有时孩子大发脾气并不是因为你对他们说了“不”，而是因为他们有
meltdown because they are overstimulated by their sensory overload in the environment, whether it's noise, light, touch. And so to assume then your child is misbehaving because you lack skills is to neglect this complex, you know, child, this complex parent-child relationship in this environment that a parent may not even understand. So I think we frame it in a way in this book to understand what Tim had talked about earlier. What are the the behaviors that you're seeing and the more intense the behavior is such as lying, aggression, deceitfulness. We need to address that first.
崩溃是因为他们被环境中的感官过载所过度刺激，无论是噪音、光线还是触觉。因此，如果认为你的孩子行为不端是因为你缺乏技能，那就是忽视了这个复杂的孩子，忽视了这种复杂的亲子关系，忽视了父母可能甚至不理解的环境。因此，我认为我们在本书中以某种方式对其进行了重新构架，以理解蒂姆之前谈到的内容。你所看到的行为是什么，行为越强烈，例如说谎、攻击性、欺骗性。我们需要先解决这个问题。
And if those things are managed, then you sort of go up this funnel and these less intense behaviors, right, are something then that you can shift your parenting goals towards. But it may look different for families based on their needs. based on the parents' own personal health, the family's health, other circumstances, difficult environments, et cetera. So yes, there are core things that we found to be really important to help sort of lead the child to success, but to say one size fits all for each family or each parent-child relationship is neglecting the complexity of us as people and as a parent and a child.
如果这些事情得到了处理，那么你就会沿着这个漏斗向上走，这些不太激烈的行为，对吧，然后就是你可以将你的育儿目标转移到的方向。但根据他们的需求，对家庭来说可能看起来有所不同。根据父母自身的健康状况、家庭健康状况、其他环境、困难环境等。所以，是的，我们发现有一些核心事情非常重要，可以帮助引导孩子走向成功，但如果说每个家庭或每个亲子关系都适用同一套标准，那就是忽视了我们作为人、作为父母和孩子的复杂性。
child together. Dr. Kavell, does that approach work when you're dealing with parents who have children who are bullies or may be bullied? I think the conditions necessary for a strong parent-child relationship are similar in terms of what's needed. What's going to differ, Kim, is what's required of a parent, depending on their child-rearing circumstances and the characteristic of the child. I mean, the research is pretty clear that children are in this world with certain endowments, genetic endowments, which influences their environment. Some children are really easy to parent. Some children are very challenging to parent. And so parents have to fit what they're doing to what their child needs.
孩子在一起。卡韦尔博士，当你面对那些有霸凌行为或可能被霸凌的孩子的父母时，这种方法管用吗？我认为，建立牢固的亲子关系所必需的条件在所需方面是相似的。不同的是，金，父母需要做什么，这取决于他们的抚养条件和孩子的特征。我的意思是，研究非常清楚，儿童带着某些天赋来到这个世界，基因天赋，这会影响他们的环境。有些孩子很容易抚养。有些孩子抚养起来极具挑战性。因此，父母必须使他们的做法适应孩子的需求。
For children who are easy temperament, meet schedules, they're compliant, cooperative, they're emotionally regulated. Parenting, I think the parent-child relationship is going to have this same three conditions except contain and lead, but parents won't have to work as hard as deliberately, and it will be fairly easy to pull that off. When you have a challenging child, you have to be more intentional and conscious and explicit about what you're trying to do. Winnicott, who coined the term good enough mother, was a big fan of ordinary parents, ordinary mothers, in the sense that he saw in ordinary parents so many.
对于那些气质随和、作息规律、顺从、合作、情绪调节能力强的孩子。育儿，我认为亲子关系将具备这相同的三个条件，除了包含和引导，但父母不需要那么刻意地努力，而且很容易做到这一点。当你有一个具有挑战性的孩子时，你必须对你试图做的事情更有意图、更有意识、更明确。温尼科特（Winnicott）创造了“足够好的母亲”这个词，他是普通父母、普通母亲的忠实粉丝，因为他从普通父母身上看到了很多。
strengths. And I think our field over time has sort of cast parenting as extraordinary, as something as a separate set of skills that you don't, you're not necessarily equipped with, that you have to go to some book or some expert for. We'd like to believe that if you can manage well your relationships, including the one with your child, you're going to be fine, but recognize that for some children, the task is going to be more challenging. And it's going I'll look a little different. Let's close with this one question. I'm going to throw it at both of you sequentially, which is for each of you, what is one
优势。我认为我们的领域随着时间的推移，把育儿描绘成非凡的，描绘成一套你未必天生具备的、必须通过某些书本或专家才能获得的独立技能。我们愿意相信，如果你能很好地管理你的人际关系，包括与孩子的那段关系，你就会过得很好，但也要认识到，对于某些孩子来说，任务会更具挑战性。而且看起来会有些不同。让我们以这个问题来结束。我将依次向你们两人提出这个问题，那就是对你们每个人来说，什么是唯一一个
piece of parenting advice that you would like to leave with our listeners? One of the things that I talk about within the beginning of the book, which when Tim approached me about writing this together, this is the first thing that came to my mind and really stuck with me when I was first learning how to be a clinical psychologist. So I'll give you, I'll give you this antidote and then I'll sort of end with what I mean by it all. So I had a parent come in and she had a young boy. And she leaned in close to me when she was trying to seek services. And she said, I love my child, but I don't like my child.
你想留给听众的育儿建议？我在书的开头谈论过的一件事，当蒂姆找我一起写这本书时，这是我脑海中浮现的第一件事，当我刚开始学习如何成为一名临床心理学家时，它深深地印在了我的脑海里。所以我会给你，我会给你这个反证，然后我将以我对这一切的理解来结束。所以我曾接待过一位母亲，她有一个小男孩。当她在寻求服务时，她凑近我。她说，我爱我的孩子，但我不喜欢我的孩子。
And it stuck with me for so long and it took a long time for me to connect and understand what that meant finally when I had my own children. But I think the point being here that there are many things that you can work on as a parent. We can always do better and seek for more for our children. And yet if we can lead with love and if we can remember that at the end of the day, our task is to love our children and be there for them and accept them, I think that is the biggest thing that needs. needs to happen first before you worry about anything else. And so there are many things we want for our children. There are many things we hope for for our children. And if we just can accept them for who they are and where they're at, I think that is the first thing you have to accomplish as a parent before you can try to do anything else. Dr. Cavell? Parenting involves the head and the
它在我心中萦绕了很久，直到我自己有了孩子，我才花了很长时间去建立联系并最终理解这意味着什么。但我认为重点在于，作为父母，有许多事情你可以努力。我们总能做得更好，为我们的孩子谋求更多。然而，如果我们能以爱为先，如果我们能记住，归根结底，我们的任务是爱我们的孩子，陪伴他们并接受他们，我认为这是在你担心任何其他事情之前最需要发生的事情。因此，我们对孩子有许多期望。我们对孩子有许多希望。如果我们能接受他们本来的样子以及他们所处的状态，我认为这是作为父母在尝试做任何其他事情之前必须完成的第一件事。卡韦尔博士？育儿涉及理智和
heart or science and art, if you will. And so some parents sometimes lead too much much with what's happening emotionally. And some parents are trying to do what the science they think is right. The science tells us this. There are some things that are important and try to emphasize those things. And our book speaks to that. And there are a lot of things that are not, that don't matter that much. And so if you want to use your mind or the science of parenting,
心，或者说是科学与艺术，如果你愿意的话。因此，有些父母有时过于倾向于情感层面发生的事情。而有些父母则试图按照他们认为正确的科学去做。科学告诉我们这些。有些事情很重要，并试图强调这些事情。我们的书就探讨了这一点。还有很多事情并不重要，其实没那么重要。因此，如果你想运用你的头脑或育儿科学，
recognize that not everything is consequential. In fact, the science of parenting would say to you very strongly, when you go to decide where to put your energies, put it on the relationship. That's where you double down. So if you're trying to decide should I put my child in time, not should I use a star chart, should I, you know, take him to a professional. Pay attention to the relationship. Is my relationship with my child healthy?
认识到并非每件事都产生重大影响。事实上，育儿科学会强烈地告诉你，当你决定把精力放在哪里时，把它放在关系上。那是你需要加倍投入的地方。因此，如果你在纠结是否应该让孩子面壁思过、是否应该使用星光表、是否应该带他去看专业人士。关注这段关系。我和我孩子的关系健康吗？
Is it strong? Has it meeting that 80-20 criteria? And if not, what can I do to bolster that relationship? And I offer that because I don't think assessing the quality of the relationship is often what parents typically go to early. Instead, they're looking for a quick answer to fix some problem as opposed to saying, how are we doing my child and I? What can I do to make that relationship strong? Maybe do I need to, does it need to be repaired in some way? Am I struggling emotionally to be available and patient with my child?
它牢固吗？它达到那个80-20的标准了吗？如果没有，我能做些什么来巩固这种关系？我提出这一点是因为我认为评估关系的质量往往不是父母通常首先做的事情。相反，他们是在寻找解决某个问题的快速答案，而不是说，我和我的孩子现在怎么样？我能做些什么来让这段关系变得牢固？也许我需要，它需要以某种方式修复吗？我在情感上很难对我的孩子保持关注和耐心吗？
What do I need to do to be an emotionally healthy parent so I can have a better relationship with my child? So it's a different way to think about parenting, not as a job where you look at an endless series of fixes, but it's about a relationship that you manage 18 plus years. Well, I want to thank you both for joining me today. I think you have provided our listeners with some excellent and sound advice. Thank you. You're welcome. Thank you for having us. And speaking of our listeners, if you would like to be able to.
我需要做什么才能成为一个情感健康的父母，以便与孩子建立更好的关系？所以这是一种思考育儿的不同方式，不是把它当成一份你需要寻找无数补救措施的工作，而是把它当成一段你需要经营18年以上的关系。好的，我想感谢你们两位今天能来。我认为你们为我们的听众提供了一些极好且稳妥的建议。谢谢。不客气。谢谢你们邀请我们。说到我们的听众，如果你想获得
like a copy of good enough parenting, you can visit the book section of our website, www.apa.org, and you can order one there. You can find previous episodes of speaking of psychology on our website at www.combeckycology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at AP. p.a.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要一本《足够好的育儿》（Good Enough Parenting），你可以访问我们网站www.apa.org的图书板块，并在那里订购。你可以在我们的网站www.apa.org/education/podcast或在Apple、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到往期的《心理学访谈》（Speaking of Psychology）节目。如果你喜欢我们节目的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至Speaking of Psychology@apa.org。《心理学访谈》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪恩（Chris Kondyne）。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。